here's what i was trying to talk about
from the ghetto
before before when i said the reason why
i don't like the democrats
is they're locking everything down
people are suffering
we're having these debates over why the
government is guaranteeing these
liability protections as well as all
this money from our from our pockets
amazon is giving us money and i simply
say to the democrats
why are you doing it and you know the
response is the response is
biden ache seeks to ease concerns about
cabinet diversity
welcome to the modern era yeah what are
they concerned about
what is what was joe biden answering
questions who's yellow are you kidding
me joe biden was asked
as a press conference not about the the
economy
okay he was he was asked a lot about a
lot a lot of stuff but why is it
that there is this is this
this is this is the issue i this is one
of the big issues those people aren't
our leaders
our leaders exist in other realms than
politics what's that i actually have
something contentious to say about this
because
we're talking about them talking about
the diversity of joe biden's
cabinet but we're not talking about them
legalizing marijuana and i also feel
like that is a huge bread and circus's
distraction
from the real issues that we're actually
facing why right now
i don't think it's good timing i just
don't agree with the timing there are
people crazy there are people in this
country who are more concerned with the
color of the individuals the the race of
the individuals
uh who are standing next to joe biden
and those are those those are the
questions
i was thinking today about physical
health about kind of what you're talking
about and like why won't biden come out
and tell people to cut sugar out of
their diet
like is it too hard for people is it he
just doesn't
have to understand modern science has
been
used by many special interests to push
certain agendas just like the sugar
industry going against
fats just like the big tobacco industry
financing a lot of doctors
there's a long story of not just yeah
there's a new meme going around
showing that doctors should should have
uh
their their medical jackets covered with
all the big pharma
i mean sponsoring them just like
politicians
have you know their logos of the of the
corporations that support them
on their suits so i i do think there's
also that element that needs to be also
recognized that there have
been scientists that have been bought
out by the special interest and said
absurd
things like cigarettes are good for you
uh that have absolutely been proven
wrong
everything's broken yeah yeah and it
deserves the highest amount of criticism
if we're gonna move forward in some way
towards fixing it i think for one uh i
was listening to a video from jordan
peterson recently
uh prager you posted it it was someone
asking about climate change and
effective leaders and jordan said clean
your room bucco
that's a simple you know paraphrasing of
what he said was but what he actually
said was
i would uh he said something to the
effect of i would be skeptical of
somebody
who was trying to clean the world when
they have not put their own home
before they've taken care of their own
personal affairs
and he said so what we need is for
people to become responsible
self-sufficient to to straighten out
their lives
before they you know eventually move on
to try and change others
but in learning how to be responsible
self-reliant uh independent they gain
those abilities to then move on to the
next step of helping others do the same
to become a leader
to make appropriate decisions so it all
starts with you
learning how to start a fire yeah how to
start a fire
i should know how to practice that i
mean really that was a big thing
this year has been huge for me when it
comes to everything that you're
mentioning right now specifically
just being stuck inside of new york city
during the supposed worst of it
during the middle of the lockdowns
during the middle of the highest
supposed epidemic and
realizing that i'm surrounded by a bunch
of unprepared individuals
that who are hungry who are hungry and
thirsty we'll do anything to survive
we're living right on top of each other
and it just
takes the trucks not coming in that's it
you know the bigger
madness but you know the big issue is
the it's there's an optimism and a
normalcy bias
so the optimism biases it can't happen
here the normalcy biases that'll never
happen
but people don't realize when it came to
say you know the fall of the soviet
union people had been living their whole
lives
generations under the system then one
day was gone there are civil wars that
broke out where people thought it would
never happen in fact in the united
states civil war
people were gathering on the hill near
was at fort sumner thinking a war will
never break out having a picnic
and then also they watch people getting
disemboweled in explosions and we're
like vomiting up their picnic like wow
it's really happening
yeah people people think you know what's
funny is
you ever watch a prepper show yes and
it's funny how people mock and ridicule
preppers you know that's always
confusing to me
you'd think a consumerist capitalist
society would venerate
preppers buy more buy 30 years of beans
and put them in your basement
bye bye bye after 9 11 happened george w
bush what did he say
um store up uh go buy go purchase go to
the mall go buy stuff
buy stuff that's why i always found it
funny that preppers were looked down
upon if anything the consumerist
americans they were targeted they were
laughed at but this year
in 2020 they came at us they came out as
the real mvps here
and i remember being in new york and
saying i need to get out of here in
march i went out to a farm in
pennsylvania and realized i have no
skills at all
i i can't do this i can't figure this
out and i was stuck
saying you know this is either going to
make me or break me i decided to move up
to new hampshire
went up there i was supposed to do a
whole tour all around the united states
but ended up staying there
on this synchronistic kind of event i
was looking for an rv found a friend who
needed one fixed
it was you know too expensive for me to
afford i ended up fixing it
at my friend jay nunes big compound
where he literally is a diesel mechanic
and fixer-upper guy who wears overalls
is covered in grease
all the time and could fix anything with
all the tools that he had in his shed
and i i spent
five months there learning just the
basics of being a mechanic just the
basics of welding and also a lot of
survival self-defense
training courses that i ended up
teaching people
so it's been something that's been
absolutely incredible living in the
middle of nowhere and there is
something to say about individuals when
they live in the country
automatically turning more either
libertarian
anarchist or right-wing because of the
self-sufficiency because of the
importance of understanding
that in nature it is wild it is crazy it
is hectic
but it's only you and yourself that are
responsible for your butt and knowing
that you know what
you know what makes people right wing
when they do this when they go through
this stuff the hard work
the hard work and then when someone
comes along imagine this you've you
worked for eight hours
you finally you know built your little
shelter you got a fire going
you caught some rabbits and then some
dude walk someone goes gonna get some of
that
you're gonna be like bro i got barely
enough for me and it was really hard to
come on dude share yeah you've got more
than me we made people work we had
chickens running around all over the
property people had to catch them with
their bare hands
during my training courses it was pretty
funny to watch because a bunch of city
slickers came
a bunch of people from boston new york
new jersey came to new hampshire for my
survival training course
and they were literally running around
trying to catch these chickens they had
to catch them
and then they had to chop off their
heads pluck them take out the organs
let's cook them eat them as they make
their own shelter
and it's a lot of work what's the best
trick to catch a fleeing chicken
uh corner it you uh you make a lasso
with uh with some twins and then you're
pulling you and you're like yeah and
sometimes even just walking straight up
and feeding it
or or birdshot oh yeah well no then
you're going to have a whole bunch of
pellets
in your chicken that you're going to try
to eat and you don't want you don't want
you know
you got you got to do some work you know
but but it is easier yeah but
you know making your own shelter making
your own fire filtering your own water
that is an extensive exhausting activity
and those are the basic necessities that
people take advantage of every single
day
after going through that chicken after
having to catch it after gutting it
after cutting it after
putting it on the plate and cooking it
you realize how absolutely absurd
it is that there's chicken thighs for a
dollar at walmart
you're like what are they doing that
they have to mass produce
such food so quickly so efficiently to
make this one dollar
when it took me all day to make this
chicken to produce it into a sustainable
meal
we need kids to experience to learn this
well
my friend jane he had man camp that's
what he called it
man and it's literally where kids come
i was part of the kids um i'm not afraid
to admit that and he teaches them just
basic things like welding using a wrench
using a hammer
making shoe horses making hangers
whatever folding steel for his katana
oh that sounds awesome
we did a lot of different stuff but um
there is something to say about this
kind of
attitude and the type of people in new
hampshire that are in the wild there's
some city folks
there's a big free state project
initiative but one thing that really
sparked
my interest in new hampshire wasn't just
the community but also
the lack of government new hampshire you
don't need car insurance you don't need
helmets you don't need seat belts when
you drive
but they have some of the safest roads
in the united states they're the number
one in homeschooling
with the highest iq in all of the united
states
they have the most bitcoin transactions
per capita go ahead wow
there's a video game youtuber yeah who
was playing a game it was called like
city states
and he normally like it's like you
choose how much taxes you want
how you like you know wages stuff like
that and then you build buildings
he decided as a gag to make a totally
lawless society
under the assumption it would be chaos
and destruction and
fighting and poverty his video is
amazing because his shock and confusion
as he removed all the laws there were no
poor people
everybody lived in luxury buildings
there was an abundance of wealth
and he's laughing like what's happening
there's no regulations
no taxes no pollution no inspiration no
poverty no crime
and and it was gone the video went crazy
get to a point where technology's so
good that we can go back to before the
era of regulations and have a new
freedom
well there's a lot of yeah if we create
like an ai that just
forces us to live under the bridge
encourages us i don't know i'm not for
that
but uh but we got crypto we have like
you know desalination
homeschooling and people arming
themselves and defending themselves in
new hampshire in record numbers and new
hampshire
is one of the most second amendment
friendly states in all of the united
states and it has the least amount of
homicides and gun deaths
in the nation so when you listen though
when you look at it's expensive when it
comes to
let's let's talk about some of the
negatives because you need to talk about
both of the sides here
you do have property taxes but you do
have record low taxes when it comes
everywhere else but the property taxes
are really high and you do have an
opioid epidemic that has hit
new hampshire extensively hard and
you're seeing the effects of it
especially in manchester
where you're seeing a lot of people
addicted to meth so there are positive
positive and negatives it does get
really cold there hence why i'm here
with you living in your parking lot
right now that's right
making my way slowly down to florida but
i will be back
in new hampshire i absolutely love it
there i love the community and i love
individuals we're gonna get a farm now
yeah so i like that idea too because we
might do i don't know if you want to
survival we might do survival trainings
but but it's not even that's about
having fun grow corn it's about making a
video of luke chasing a chicken around
yeah
it's amazing once you get into this hard
work
it's so fun it's so rewarding and it's
so
amazing to be able to do this stuff even
though it is difficult but
that's what life is you know life if
everything was easy if everything was
handed to you if democrats and
the globalists had their way and they
would give you everything
you wouldn't appreciate it and it would
be filled with you walking to walmart
and you're like
i'll just take two fried chickens yes
whole
chickens no dude every time i walk into
walmart i'm like
how much of this are we wasting i hate
it so much i hate that feeling
and what you were talking about raising
kids to like take care of chickens and
stuff like your little camp your little
kids camp
that's how i was raised i remember i
raised chickens to lay eggs that was my
first job now this is my question
towards tim you raise a country like
that that's armed that prepares their
own food
that is ready for fascism that doesn't
need any government that doesn't need
anything
how will the chinese invade like like
what was the thing though oh it's
what was the thing that the japanese
people said when they when they when
they were talking about that's not a
real question
it's not a rifle behind every blade of
grass
yeah do you wanna know how they'll
invade exactly culturally
no neural net no uh it's called a bunch
of individuals who are responsible only
to themselves and surviving for
themselves
one day a businessman comes along and
says uh we want to
get a proposition for you and we'll pay
you a really great rate to do x y or z
and they'll say yes
and then they start getting this money
and they don't want to back down and
they say now do this now do this now do
this
and slowly but surely they increment
people towards policies that benefit
them
and then you end up with a chinese
businessman comes and buys massive swash
of property across the western united
states and people just say
yeah amazing maybe what literally
happened
yeah that's exactly what's happening
right now but you have a whole bunch of
lemmings whole bunch of unprepared
people
with their flip flops and their lattes
being on the government
teeth that aren't even questioning it or
or doing anything to
ask your question and are being
independent shout out to
if a if a chinese businessman came to
you and offered you half a million
dollars for your rv would you say yes
for my uh yeah sure of course you would
and then you'd be like wow now they own
your rv that's what they're doing with
land
and people are going wow and life
insurance policies have you seen those
commercials where they want to buy your
life insurance policy
if you don't need your life insurance
policy i haven't seen that it's
insidious people are i don't know about
you desperate for money right it's on
keeps
it's crazy but what future do you think
is possible if people
became self-sustainable do you think my
future or tim should we do like a voting
thing
i think without one without a cohesive
community yeah you'll end up with
but i think we have an identity um
as people and i think that an identity
and i think a culture should come first
and should be prioritized because right
now
culture is being thrown into the trash
it has the worst elements in it right
now that are highlighted
it's dominating the most degenerate uh
disgusting behavior possible that breaks
up the family unit
if you look at what they're pushing out
there in mainstream culture it's drugs
it's alcohol it's chemicals
it's it's you now even have mainline
rappers
talking about the latest medicine that
they want to introduce with themselves
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait cough syrup hold on that's
literally what you can
aspire to be you married not yet how old
are you i don't know
how hell did i look like genetically
yeah
34. 34 years old you gotta get any kids
um working on it thirty four nine maybe
we'll see
no kids driving around in an rv you uh
mr mr dmt psychedelics ayahuasca the
thing is there's
this judgment here you're
yes and you contribute to that culture
depends maybe
but not to the extensive elements of
totally selling out we all sell out in
some ways
that's basically undeniable because you
there's no other way in mainline
uh society right now of course uh but
again we all strive towards being
something better
and i think striving is the first step
into getting it
and i am making decisions and goals that
are a lot different
than they were when they were influenced
by culture because growing up in new
york city growing up in brooklyn
i was absolutely influenced by the worst
elements
of mainstream society and their ideas of
glorifying drug dealers and glorifying
violence and glorifying this idiocy i
was an absolute total victim of it and i
perpetrated it
to the fullest extent well whatever you
know what i mean
i'm just you know speaking expressively
here but
essentially when it comes to
understanding it that is the first step
towards defeating it
and we could all be better and i'm
making decisions to be as best as i can
and i'm making the best decision to move
away from that and move forward
towards the family and kids and thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you